[Music]
so make sure that you're not in the
joint
okay so if we if we look at
his
uh
hand to mine it's much bigger amazing
i you look at his
arm to my arm
it's much bigger okay
i cannot i cannot do this joint pain on
him don't hurt me but just slowly pull
out of it
okay
um
that's not what you're doing
so if you come around here you're in his
block you're in his body
just because i've been i have the nico
in place
it's not that i go joint pain
just the same way that
his body this way right
same way i'm just in his body this way
you see in his his body i just hold it
in there and then i go into his body
again
okay
so make sure
when you're here
in the body
in his body
technique
so come around find this box
body
right
don't crank get
try to get out of his joint
not in his joint okay
go okay so now when you come to your
shoulder you will feel that well now my
small hands
are supported by this third hand here on
my chest you get it
like you don't no
it doesn't make you're still not going
to go into the joint you're going to
stay into
into his body
my chest is doing it
see that arm and that chest is still
doing it
don't come here and try to crank him
down
your chest is still
still doing it okay i'm still in his
body
with the tip
[Music]
do you understand so that's why we do
the other one because there's
once you're mismatched you can't be in
the joint you'll feel how weak you are
but now you have the third
angle to close it but don't do it
stay in his body
instead
[Music]
body is okay
don't come here and clap
positions
okay so this one goes
uh you're gonna it's gonna be even more
trapped
so here
here
it's it's easy for someone to force your
way out the bottom
just rip i'll do it
got me
okay
are you gonna increase your
uh leverage on everything
by being up here okay
but it's gonna be the same thing
don't crank and attack the joint
move his center
okay so this technique you haven't seen
it before it doesn't go on your forehead
it goes on top of your head
okay
on top of your head so one two and then
your head is filling up that third hand
but
you stay
in the body
don't attack the joint
pull here
[Music]